hi there i'm rachael lee cook from love
guaranteed on netflix and today i'm
going to be taking a quiz to find out
if i didn't care much so much about
buzzfeed this wouldn't be happening what
rachel lee
cook character i am i can't wait
i still can't believe i'm at quiz status
right now i'm kind of freaking out
how would your friends describe you
creative
funny loyal honest impulsive
or smart these all presume a lot of my
friends
if we're being optimistic here i'm not
sure about funny but that's the one i
would hope for so i'm gonna say
funny is it possible to fail this quiz
pick something from the 90s you'd want
in your babysitter's club kid kit would
i want
hogs beanie babies tamagotchis
butterfly clips or jelly sandals i gotta
go with cassette tapes
nostalgia what can i say choose a song
from josie and the pussycats
ah this one's gonna be tough three small
words
pretend to be nice spin around you're a
star
you don't see me or come on
i don't remember come on the hardest one
to play
of all of these songs is three small
words because it's not a ton of chords
but oh my god it's fast
really ripped up my hands guys i love
the beautiful simplicity of pretend to
be nice
it really creeps up on you you know spin
around though
has got the best ramp up and payoff
you don't see me as a mood though i
gotta go three small words
what can i say but truthfully my
favorite songs on that soundtrack are
all by du jour and if you've seen the
movie you know what i'm talking about
now choose a laney bugs look
the classic kiss me red dress look the
falafel hat
the artsy look the prom look the
performance
look the beach look you know normally i
would say the artsy look
but what's appealing to me right now in
this state that the world is in
is totally the performance look it looks
like i'm going to go perform at an edm
show later and i'm very into that
pick a 90s bots teen star to hang out
with
uh freddie prince jr i haven't seen him
recently
we were texting the other week about
something
that cannot be discussed yet but we have
been in touch
gabrielle union james van der beek
larissa olenek oh
jonathan taylor thomas or rosario dawson
funny enough
my friend tamara mello from
she's all that is one who rented this
cabin that we're at right now
i feel like that would make people very
happy she's the one who's like lainey
you throw it you like you run like a
girl or you throw like a girl or
something
hey tam do you want to say hi to
buzzfeed
it was worth a try my first instinct was
gabrielle because i adore her and i
haven't
seen her forever but i might have to
weirdly go with jonathan taylor thomas
just because i'm
so curious as to what that guy is up to
right now
finally pick a show to binge on netflix
here we go
stranger things the babysitter's club
riverdale
or just the new black the great british
baking show
or selling sunset i am loyal and
the expression is bsc forever so yeah
the babysitter's club
of course oh
i'm a marianne oh no no one wants to be
mary anne oh dear you're marianne speer
you're definitely shy and often play by
the rules
but you're a fiercely loyal friend who
speaks up for what's right i do
i do that you're the most organized
member of the bsc by far
that's so funny who wouldn't want to be
more of a josie than a marianne or
more of a ginger than a marianne but you
know what marianne did pull a lot higher
than ginger so you know what fine
you